the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to talk about
Daario naharis and his role in the
upcoming seasons the last scene in which
we saw Daario was in the season 6 finale
in which Daenerys was about to set sail
was about to leave for Westeros
but before she could have done it she
had to break her ties with Daario
Tyrion's prompting fearing that bringing
Daario to Westeros would be a detriment
to her cause as Daenerys is finally
heading to Westeros with her two big
armies with her advisors and with her
allies darian the second son's are left
in Mereen to keep and to enforce the
Queen's peace in over dimensioned
greatest city-state of the bay of
dragons marine along with two other
great city-state better part of the
former slavers Bay until the people
choose their own rulers Daario naharis
the man that appeared in more than 20
episodes so far the man that killed his
superiors upon receiving commands that
he didn't like that he didn't want to
obey the man that was sold by his own
mother to a slave master from tolls due
to his aggressive unruly behavior and
tendency to get into fights the same man
was trained as a bit fighter was one of
the best if not the best fighter who
wanted many fights that he was able to
buy his freedom his highly skilled
warrior and already proven commander
after all this being said we can say for
sure that this same man
Dorian Harris is a man of action a man
that most certainly won't just slide his
sword down being marine with his Salford
company the second son's doing nothing
while his queen is going to face a lot
of enemies a lot of battles in which
Dorian his second son's would be more
than helpful but let's assume the Dorian
his self third company are going to obey
the any soldiers that they're going to
enforce the Queen's peace in the bay of
dragons for a few months until people
choose the rulers but what then what
will happen after people choose their
rulers I don't know about you but I can
imagine this character disappearing and
never showing up again not after he
played his role in 21 episodes of total
60 not to resolve his commanding skills
and his brilliant strategy mind that he
revealed in already mentioned last scene
of his in which he was left
kind in that same scene upon Danny's
payment that he is not coming with
current her armies Dario replied with
new strategy you want a second sample
tag from the best girl to take Casterly
Rock
so that Lannisters would have nowhere to
run the nearest might have partially
made a good decision leaving dari behind
but on the other hand she has also done
a terrible mistake
which is going to figure out when she
carries out an ambush that is going to
take place in the middle of the upcoming
season a confirmed battle in which Danny
writing drawn and for the tragic order
going to attack Lannister's army with
Jaime Lannister on its head and Tardos
army with Randall and deacon on its head
an ambush that will happen while those
two armies are heading home upon
defeating Tyrell forces and upon
conquering Highgarden the same ambush
will resulted in a versus victory and
while Randall and Deakin are going to be
captured Jaime and Bronn will somehow
manage to escape in the heat of the
battle will run in hide in Casterly Rock
which table to be able to do if Danny
had accepted arias idea if the nail is
didn't lead Arion marine but accepted
his suggestion in which he would lead
the second sons would attack the west
coast would take the Casterly Rock
Lancer stronghold there also floating
around a few tier is the Daario and his
self sword company that fight for coin
and for highest bidder are going to be
bought by the Lannisters of urine
Greyjoy
theories in which Daria would arrive at
Westeros with his second sons and would
fight against his lover Daenerys
in my opinion it's certainly an
interesting possibility as he did kill
his last two superior support living in
orders he didn't want to obey but I
don't think the same is going to happen
in this case while on the other hand I
think that at some point of the upcoming
seasons Dora will arrive at his second
son's at Westeros but not as Danny's
enemy but as her Savior at this point
it's not even a theory but rather of
fact that Daenerys will in the very
beginning of season 7 will score two
allies Baloo's Yaron through gradual
forces along with her second ally the
same snakes and their forces as a result
of those two being defeated from your
great joy and his iron fleet upon
attacking urine in order to take the
Iron Islands under ers rule the Vantage
firstly was
but after not that long became a certain
event of the upcoming season there's a
lot of leaked photos confirmed it in
conclusion
Daria might come to Westeros has been
Savior as a man that was left behind but
also the plum commander with highly
marbled strategy mind and a big amount
of soldiers which Danny would be happy
to see if her army decided this point
already destroyed allies would also
start decreasing its numbers due to a
few battles such as ambush on Tarla
stand Lannisters who had joined forces
will manage to defeat her last Ally
Terrell's
in my opinion it's possible the Daario
who beside his loyalty towards Danny
also Lazar they'll show up after a short
absence and will arrive at Westeros in
the crucial moments in order to provide
his queen and lover more soldiers and in
order to provide for a new general
advisor and Fred geez that Daria truly
is let me know what you think about all
of this in the comment section down
below do you think the darkness has
already played his role and that
showrunners decided to simply leave him
behind instead of killing him or do you
think the Daria was left behind as some
sort of cliffhanger only to appear as
Danny's Savior let me know your thoughts
in the comment section hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
you